absolutely not I think if anything we
have to work harder because there's so
many options that people have and and so
in order to sustain it it takes a lot
more active engagement it's been
fascinating you know my career has
spanned a lot of years from the 70s
until where we are today and you know
before I won't say you could almost take
your consumer for granted but you know
there were there weren't as many options
to choose from
so you had a certain number of we call
them SKU stock-keeping units of a cereal
brand now there are rows and rows and
shelves and shelves and aisles and so
how do you get a person to continue to
want to pick yours versus trying
something else and so you have to do be
more active in engaging with people to
find out what do they like about their
product what would they like see
different and understanding what they
like about the competition I think there
was a time when people didn't think
about what are the other options out
there and I think there's a lot of time
now it's spent saying what are people's
options and maybe what are their sort of
indirect options you know for example
you know there's a generation that used
to get up every morning and drink coffee
right now there's a generation that gets
up and drinks a carbonated soft drink
and never even touches a cup of coffee
unless occasionally they might stop off
at a Starbucks which is in their mix but
but again it's it's a dynamic that
people need to think more broadly about
what are what are the other options and
then it becomes exciting because you
figure out how to make that connection
with your customer as we say really love
your customer and I just sort of say you
know ok we're going to do everything to
keep them but but you really love your
customer
it's interesting to look at the ones
that have remained strong like JPMorgan
Chase which has remained strong through
all of this in part because I I believe
the JPMorgan culture and heritage is
something that has really sustained them
it was about integrity it was about
business relationships and they've used
that and they've behaved in that fashion
and so it there's been a continuity for
some that have have been absorbed in the
process of this what I call economic
transformation I think in many ways some
of them sort of lost their authenticity
that true north where they came from and
I think companies look at a Wells Fargo
which is very strong out west I think
they're they have stayed strong and are
continuing to do things to say strong
even as they absorb the Wachovia vis of
the world and one of the things that's
going to be I think very interesting and
you've seen this consolidation in many
consumer packaged goods I mean I worked
for one I worked for General Foods if
you ask somebody today
of a certain generation with General
Foods they'd be clueless and one of the
you know largest consumer products
company which then merged with Kraft and
over time became what they called one
Kraft and so now there's a whole
communication around building that brand
and I think it's really sort of laying
the framework for people to understand
almost more understand your values right
because that's what people link to in
establishing brand relationships I
believe over the long term and you had
asked a question about loyalty it's
about what that relationship is it's not
always well this brand will make your
clothes two times whiter than something
else
yeah that's an element of it but what
I'll see you doing around the world how
are you helping in sustainability so
that you have a brand that maybe I don't
have to use as much water
maybe I don't have to rinse my hair
quite as much because I'm concerned
about water usage or maybe you can come
up with some different products for my
hair and cleansing my hair or I don't
have to use water so those are the kinds
of things but you're showing me that you
care about the environment you care
about me and the things that are
important